[Applause]
even our looks are incredulous
this Easter of war
too much blood we have seen too much
violence our hearts are also filled with
fear and anguish while many of our
brothers and sisters have had to
lock themselves inside to defend themselves from
bombs
may peace be upon the  battered ukraine
so severely tried by the violence
and destruction of the cruel and
senseless war she was dragged
into this terrible night of suffering
and death
now soon a new dawn of
hope choose peace stop
flexing your muscles while people suffer
please please
unaccustomed to war let us
all pledge to cry for
peace from the balconies and in the streets
patch it is the
clear responsibility of the nations
listen to the people's right to peace i
will carry in my heart
all the many ukrainian victims
the millions of refugees and displaced
internal families divided the elderly left
alone
of broken lives
and razed cities a  the soil
brothers and sisters
let us win the peace of christ
peace is
possible peace is a duty peace is
everyone's primary responsibility
[Applause]